did you choose Beyonce for a partnership
did she choose you to be honest the
first conversation really was them
talking to talking to to me to us I
don't want to do a collaboration I said
let's go and build a proper
brand and see how we could develop a
brand that's got long you know got
staying
power proper distribution Channel why is
it important for the business to be
separate with Beyonce why is it not a
collaboration like what you did with
Kate Moss you know I mean I think there
I think sort of those type of
collaborations
shortterm fine produce a range in out
gone and that wasn't I I I think this is
a sector I think that's interesting
that's growing people are wearing
athletic wear Leisure wise as well as
going to the gym or dancing or going to
these different places so I think it's
got a much broader use
now um and I don't think you can find
anybody
better it' be difficult to find anybody
one of the most exciting exting things
again with Beyonce is just sort of the
online capability of the type of content
I hope we can produce of workout dance
gym you know music I mean a sort of a
lot of other pieces to get the customer
engaged and I think that piece of it is
going to be very exciting what's the
outlook for that business obviously
athleisure is very hot growing I think
we haven't we haven't made the first
samples yet it's got 19 million
Instagram followers or 13 14 you know we
got a shop
right I really don't even want to bring
Olivia on now why because shouldn't you
be wearing a sequins unitard if we're
talking Top Shop and Beyonce that's the
image well I mean Hello as soon as they
go on sale and seven to eight months as
soon as I can actually get my hands on a
beyon seard I will be wearing one on
market makers are they going to really
make a sequins unitard is that I'm not
sure if you're being serious we being
serious uh when was the last time you
went to Top Shop I mean that's the look
I've never been to Top Shop I lived in
London for three years and I've never
been there but you do own multiple pairs
of leather pants but in all sincerity
when you ask why wouldn't you do a
similar collaboration to Kate Moss is it
that they can't it's Beyonce she would
just simply demand too much perhaps this
is going to be completely separate
separate business separate overhead
separate offices it is a 50/50
partnership the clothes the sequin
unitards are going to be called Park
shop Parkwood Top Shop athletic you know
all about the business of Beyonce she
already actually has a fashion line
through the house of Darion which she's
been her mom uh this is going to be much
much bigger top chop obviously this huge
Global Launchpad for Beyonce but I was
very interested to hear that sir Phillip
who by the way is walking around with a
1990s Nokia phone who knows nothing
about technology flip no well it's just
sort of like this that's amazing he has
many of them he does not I'm not even
sure he knows how to email he did though
know the statistics Beyonce's Instagram
followers and Twitter followers because
he's a Savvy retailer and he's very
tuned in to her viral marketing power